viennent de s'abattre sur la gare de
kramatorz
ek décor jonge encore le sol près des
quais
des civils tués alors qu'il tentait de
fuir en train
explosé tout d'un coup beaucoup de gens
sont morts
nous connaissons très bien cette gare
nous y tournons depuis trois jours
c'est l'endroit où sont rassemblés les
civils qui quittent cette région est de
l'Ukraine
une femme étant larmes l'un de ses
proches a été tué sur le coup
plus loin une peluche sur le quai et
devant la gare un homme hébété
il venait d'arriver avec sa grand-mère
au moment de la frappe
je viens juste de sortir son corps sans
vie de la voiture
j'étais parti acheter des cigarettes
là-bas et ça a bombardé et j'ai vu que
ma grand-mère était morte
j'ai couru pour aider des gens plus loin
un peu plus loin là-bas
devant la gare cette femme elle voulait
partir
j'ai eu de la chance j'étais de l'autre
côté des quais devant la gare sur la
pelouse l'un des deux missiles russes
avec cette inscription elle signifie
pour nos enfants
ce sont les fascistes russes ils ont
même écrit sur cet engin que c'était
pour venger leurs enfants
stupéfiante attaque car voici à quoi
ressemblait cet endroit où nous étions
ces derniers jours
de longues files d'attente pour tenter
de prendre un train vers l'ouest du pays
et à l'intérieur une gare bondée en
permanence
un endroit désormais synonyme de
violence aveugle beaucoup de blessés
sont encore entre la vie et la mort dans
les hôpitaux de la région